foreign
[Music]
college boy yeah they want to get mixed
up in a family business I mean the fun
of being an actor being somebody else
for three months you know and you just
do what I tell you to do James died last
night at the age of 82. celebs reactions
have poured in including his Godfather
co-star Al Pacino who tells ET it's hard
to believe that he won't be in the world
anymore because he was so alive and
daring his funny lady co-star Barbara
Streisand said he was so talented Adam
Sandler posted never ever stopped
laughing when I was around that man
James career spanned seven decades
including misery and elf a role he
almost passed on they called me and said
we're sending you this group called elf
and I said no you're not you're not
sending me a picture called elf I never
really saw myself doing anything with
Santa Claus you know what I mean
I love you I love you
oh
it's weird he leaves behind five
children including his son Scott who
followed his dad's footsteps come on
give me another hug this is uh my son
Scott my 16 year old as of yesterday
we're here really a short time you know
and uh
I find that out more and more every day
what I want to teach my son
who's five Scott uh is laugh as much as
you can you know that's what's important
[Music]